[Music]
Hello, Secrets Unsealed and Some TV
family. My name is Sierra Murray, and it
is my privilege and pleasure to welcome
you once again to this edition of I'd
like to know, our Bible question and
answer program. to my left, Pastor David
Salazar, who superintends our Latino
work, general manager of some TV Latino.
David, as always, good to have you here.
Thank you, Pastor. It's a blessing to me
going to be here. And to my right, our
August founder and uh lead speaker here
at the ministry, Pastor Steven Boore,
friend to all, and uh really good guy to
work for. Amen. Amen.
We always have a good time on this
program because it gives us a chance to
do something that we love to do and that
we would do even if we didn't have the
program and that's study the word of
God. I'd like to know is a question and
answer program. You send in the
questions by the grace of God. We give
you the answers and we promise to give
you those answers from the word of God
if an answer can indeed be found. To
open up our program, Pastor Boore, would
you ask God's blessing upon our sitting
today? Sure. Father in heaven, we come
before your awesome throne. We come
boldly, but we also come humbly because
we come in the name of Jesus. Amen. We
have some very interesting questions
today, complex questions in some cases,
but we know that your holy word has the
answers to our questions. So, I ask that
you will be with us in this program.
Give us clarity of thought. Give us
strong voices. And bless those who are
watching the program that they might
gain not only intellectual knowledge but
a closer walk with Jesus. Amen. We pray
in his holy name. Amen. Amen. Amen. This
one is from anonymous and uh we don't
have a name but they do tell us that the
program has been a blessing for which we
praise the Lord. My question is, what is
the difference between legal
justification and experiential
justification? What does Romans chapter
5 verse 10 verse 12 and:es
18-19, what do they mean? Uh, then there
are some Ellen White statements. So
maybe we'll take off, we'll draw a line
here and go through Romans, answer these
first two questions, and then weigh
through the rest of the uh the issues.
All right. So let me read Romans 5 and
uh verses 10, 12, 18, and
19. I'm reading from the King James
version. It says, "For if when we were
enemies, we were reconciled to God
through the death of his son, much more
having been reconciled, we shall be
saved by his life." Verse 12, therefore,
just as through one man sin entered the
world, and death through sin, and thus
death spread to all men, because all
sinned. Verse 18 and 19. Therefore, as
though one man's offense judgment came
to all men, resulting in condemnation,
even so through one man's righteous act,
and the free gift came to all men,
resulting in justification of life. For
as by one man's disobedience, many were
made sinners, so also by one man's
obedience, many will be made righteous.
So these are the verses that that he uh
is quoting this the question and is
asking for its meaning.
He also asked the difference between
legal justification and exper exper
experiential justification. Perhaps we
should back into this.
Uh the Bible tells us that we became
enemies with God when man sinned. Mhm.
For the first time, the relationship was
fractured. Adam and Eve ran from God
instead of running to him. Mhm. They hid
themselves, right? Uh from God. So there
was a basic change in the relationship.
So from that
time until the death of Christ on the
cross, there was this adversarial
relationship. Correct. There was this
distance that that Christ bridged uh
when he went to the cross. and he he he
solved the sin problem. So while we were
yet enemies, while we are yet estranged
from God, the plan of salvation was put
into effect. Uh Christ was going to
come. Christ was going to say that that
process was begun before the foundations
of the world were laid. So Christ was
always going to be there uh to to bridge
over the gap that existed between man
and and God because of sin.
So
um one man got us into this fix that is
Adam. One God man got us out of this fix
and that was Jesus Christ the righteous.
Um through Adam's sin we all have become
enemies because we have all sinned. But
righteousness is available to us now as
we choose to follow Jesus and as one man
sort of dug the hole, Christ got us out
of the hole. One man got us in, one man
got us out.
You know there uh the regarding the
question of u legal
justification, there's two ideas uh in
the Adventist church. One is that God
justified the entire human race at the
cross.
The other idea which is the traditional
idea and I believe to be the biblical
one is that a person is justified when
they have faith in Jesus. They confess
their sins and uh they repent of their
sins. Um let me just read here a portion
of the parable of the uh Pharisee and
the publican. Mh. Because that's the
only time that the word justify Mhm. is
used is in the lips of Jesus, right? You
know, that's a common word for Paul. But
for Jesus, this is the only time. Let me
just read not about the Pharisee. The
Pharisee was self-justified. In other
words, he's lost. But uh but it says in
verse 13 of Luke 18, "And the tax
collector standing aar off would not so
much as raise his eyes to heaven, but
beat his breast, saying, God be merciful
to me a sinner."
Now the question is, when was this man
justified? Was he justified in a
universal justification of the entire
human race? The answer is no. because it
continues saying in verse 14, I tell you
this man went down to his house
justified
rather than the other. Uh Ellen White
states that
justification and forgiveness are one
and the same thing. Now that's true that
justification and forgiveness are the
same thing. Then this individual was
forgiven or justified when he went to
the temple to pray. Precisely. Very very
clearly the parable makes it clear. um
that he was justified when he actually
uh went and he prayed in the temple. Uh
now we need to we need to then remember
that the
provision for forgiveness was made for
the entire human race. Yes. For every
for the whole world. For everyone in the
world. The provision.
However, the application of it is only
when a person appropriates.
Exactly. provision that Christ has made.
Amen. Uh and uh you know the most famous
verse in the
Bible is which one? It appears between
the football goalposts. I'll give you a
hint. John 3:16. Everybody puts them.
Yeah. And people don't realize that that
verse has two sides. Mhm. It says, "For
God so loved the world that he gave his
only begotten son." For for how many did
he give his begotten son? for the world.
For the world, for the world. But
there's a second after the verse. There
is that everyone
who believes in him
should not perish but have everlasting
life. Uh you know I like to illustrate
it with a gift. You know for Mother's
Day we buy gifts for our wives. So let
me ask you how much did the gift cost
us? Let's say it cost $100. The gift
that we bought. Mhm. How much does it
cost our wife? Right. This is a gift.
It's a gift. It does. You know, the
person who gives the gift pays, right?
Jesus bought the gift and he paid. But
let me ask you, does the wife have an
option to reject the gift? Yeah. I don't
want that gift, you
cheapkate. Of course, she has the right
to reject the gift. If she rejects the
gift, it doesn't benefit her anyway.
Mhm. Another way of expressing it is
that Jesus deposited
in the bank of heaven enough merit to
sell the whole human race. Yes. But we
have to come to make the withdrawal. You
got to make you got to register. I I
mean it's not it's not rocket science
really. No. And and and you know pastor
this is why the verses that we read in
Romans I mean Paul speaks and he
mentions three times pretty much you
know through a man we were you know all
sin came to us because of men death came
from one for one. So we actually became
sort of slaved or we were sold out to
another another lord another system we
were taken away from God. Christ came
to re reclaim or give us the opportunity
for us to turn and to come back to him.
But again, it has to be a a choice, an
initial choice. Not everyone will accept
that. Not everyone even that come that
professes to follow the Lord will
actually accept that because to accept
the the gift of God, the grace of God
means like you said, you need to repent.
Repentance from your sins, sorrow for
your sins, and asking the Lord to
forgive you for your sins and to forsake
your sins is the step to be able to
receive that justification, that
experimental experience where you can,
like Christ said, you are justified. But
if you just live in sin and you just
say, "Lord, I believe in Christ. I
believe in Jesus, but I don't really
want to honor him in my life. I don't
want to surrender my my will and my
heart to the Lord." That's not truly
believing in the Lord. is just like like
like James says you know you believe in
God the you know the devil and the
angels believe in God too you know so
that's not what it means believing means
an action of actually accepting his
forgiven his his his pardon but also
having the desire to get rid of the sin
in your life it's really trusting the
word the word believe has been misused
because we think of it as an
intellectual exercise correct true but
really in the Bible pist and pist duel,
which are the Greek words, they mean to
trust.
The people in Hebrews, the book of
Hebrews, they trusted the Lord. Yes.
Moses said, you know, I'm going to leave
and I know that God's going to take
care. And Abraham says, I don't know
where I'm going, but I'm going to obey
the Lord. He trusted the Lord. And and
so faith is an action word. It means
trusting God enough, right, to obey him.
You know there's another verse which is
powerful says if we confess our sins
right yeah he is faithful and just to
forgive our sins which is the same as
justification and to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness. So when does
forgiveness or when does justification
take place as far as the person is
concerned? It's when the person
confesses confesses their sin,
repents and asks the Lord for
forgiveness. Then that person receives
justification which is attributed to him
or to her. In other words, it is
credited to our account. Yes. Even
though we didn't earn it, right? Jesus
bought the gift and he puts the gift to
our account. Amen. Righteousness. Yeah.
And Christ looks at us as if we had
never sinned. Right. In other words, he
sees us in the beloved. Amen. Uh at the
moment that we accept the provision. And
you know, there's been this debate uh
CA, I know that you've been around for a
long time of the Adventist Church.
There's this this debate. Did the
atonement end at the
cross? Well, people like Desmond Ford
said yes. Jesus said it is finished. The
atonement ended at the cross. But then
Ellen White says that Jesus went to
heaven. Yes. To do an atonement. So you
say who's right, Desmond Ford or Ellen
White? The fact is that both of them are
are right. Uh Jesus completed the
sacrificial aspect of the atonement. In
other words, the provision aspect of the
atonement. That's what I've got. And he
went to heaven to apply the atonement to
those who who ask him to be their
mediator. Exactly. So it, you know,
people make these dilemmas and these
contradictions that are only in their
brain. Uh so so I hope that this helps
this person who was asked the question.
We have some questions also about uh
some Ellen White statements here too. So
yeah, it's it's it's a great question
and if you take nothing else away, I've
got it written in all caps here.
Provision. He made provision. Now you've
got to accept the provision and apply it
to your life. And the moment you do so,
you are instantaneously given the credit
for being righteous in the Lord's sight.
And we praise the Lord for that. All
right. What does Ellen White mean by
these statements? Hopefully you can get
these in before our time uh slips away
from us. With his own blood, he signed
the Emancipation Papers of the race.
Well, uh what does the word emancipation
mean? It means to free. Yeah. The act of
free. Those who are under bondage or
something else. Okay. So, with his own
blood, he freed us. He went to the
cross. His blood freed us. Ellen White
says in the book Steps of Christ, there
were angels there, there could be found
in heaven angels who wanted to do it,
but it wasn't enough because the sin was
too great. It took the blood of of of
the creator to do it. And so with his
blood, he signed the emancipation of the
race. Yeah. It's kind of like It's kind
of like a slave. Mhm. Who says, "I don't
want to be free." Exactly. I still want
to be I still want to be a slave. Well,
he will remain a slave, right? Jesus
signed the im emancipation papers for
everyone who has ever lived.
But we have to choose whether we want to
live as free people or whether we want
to remain slaves. Exactly. It's just
what we were talking about. Absolutely.
So, this actually proves or affirms what
we were mentioning. Yeah. And it's so
sad how many people like slavery uh as
opposed to freedom. So sad. The sinner
must trample upon the crucified redeemer
heir he can pass onward to a life of
sin. It's it's it's aative statement or
or well air means or else. Or else.
Yeah. Basically, you've got to reject
Christ in treaties. You've got to close
your ears, lock the door. Uh if you want
to live in sin, you've got a a a savior
who is constantly calling. He's
incessantly consistently persistently
calling, begging, uh, cajoling you to
come. And if if you want to move on to a
life of sin, you got to reject all of
those intreaties uh by the Lord. That
says to me,
yeah, and this actually sort of connects
you to the versing that we found in
Hebrews chapter 10. And it says there
verse 29 uh or verse 28 or 289 rather.
says, "Of how much worse punishment do
you suppose will he be thought worthy
who has trampled the son of God
underfoot, counted the blood of the
covenant by which he was sanctified as a
common thing and insulted the spirit of
grace." So in other words, when you
reject God, when you reject the Lord,
the provision that he has made, when you
are uh trampling upon the
redeemer, that is what's going to cause
you to continue in a life of sin, to
continue in a life of slavery to sin.
And ultimately the result of those
individuals like like Paul says you know
here in the Hebrews uh the punishment
will be severe because you rejected that
power to be emancipated from from sin to
have that freedom to choose now have the
law of liberty in your heart to be able
to choose the right path to be able to
reject the temptation of the enemy.
This is why she's mentioning here that a
sinner, that one that wants to continue
in a life of sin, must reject the Lord
and the provision he has made so that he
can continue in that pilot life of sin.
Amen. Well said, pastor. Anything? No,
not at this point. But we have uh one
other quotation. Yeah, another one. I
knew you're holding your your your fire
for that. The sinner may resist the
love, may refuse to be drawn to Christ,
but if he does not resist, he will be
drawn to Jesus. Amen. The knowledge of
the plan of salvation will lead him to
the foot of the cross. Powerful
statement. I think that statement is
pretty much self-explanatory. Indeed, it
will. You know, it's giving you two
options. If you resist the love uh and
you don't want to be drawn to Christ,
that's one side. But if you don't
resist, you'll be drawn to Jesus. The
knowledge of the plan of salvation will
lead him to the foot of the cross. So
the big question is, will we resist or
not? Exactly. Mhm. And there's nothing
more powerful to see a person who has
been, you know, in sin, who has been
enslaved, enslaved to sin, who listens
to the voice of God and listens to the
gospel, the good news of salvation and
accepts that invitation and comes, you
know, not because of any human, you
know, or or financial gain or anything
like that. because he comes because he
recognizes that the Lord has loved him,
has provided enough for him to to
forgive his sins. And when that person
comes to the Lord, the change, the the
experience of rejecting that the evil
ways of the past, it's something that
comes naturally because he's in love
with the Lord and he accepts him in his
heart. So this is why she says that, you
know, if he doesn't resist, he will be
drawn to the Lord. And we have seen so
many times people coming to the Lord
because they are drawn to Christ. And
there's nothing like the Lord who who
really draws all to himself as he said
he would. I think we're going to leave
uh number 37 on the back burner for next
time too. But there's the one last
question pastor I think we can discuss
that says what did Christ accomplish on
the cross? What did he accomplish on the
cross? Well, Jesus came to this world
for two reasons primarily. He came for
other reasons but two main reasons.
Number one, to weave a robe of per
perfect righteousness by perfect
obedience
for every person who has ever lived.
Yeah, he weaved the robe. Secondly, to
pay the penalty to die for sin. So he
came to live and to die because even if
he weaved a robe, we're still guilty for
our sins. Yeah. So he came to live a
perfect life so that he could cover us
with his robe of righteousness and he
came also to die to pay for the penalty
of our sins. Amen. Uh and Jesus
accomplished both of those. Yeah. Jesus
lived a sinless life. He weaved a
perfect robe of righteousness that
anybody can claim as their own so that
they their nakedness the shame of their
nakedness can be uh covered. Yeah. But
at the same time, he bore the sins of
the whole world upon himself. But once
again, we need to respond and we need to
appropriate ourselves of what he did.
Right? He made provision as we said a
bit earlier. Now, we must appropriate
the the the benefits of that of that
provision. And this is why we're to, you
know, spend time in the scene of the
cross daily if we could, you know, to
reflect upon the sacrifice, the what it
cost our salvation, how much the love of
the Lord has been shown and given to us
so that we can re, you know, respond
with with that attraction to the Lord
and and try to to uh ask him in our
hearts to be able to really transform us
to his likeness. Um, one last thing that
I wanted to maybe ask, maybe this is
more of a question I would like to ask
you both. Wouldn't you say also that in
the cross, Christ not only he gave us
the experience of life or or or the
opportunity to live and then of course
overcoming uh or paying the penalty of
our sins, but also through his death in
the cross, he also was able to have
victory over death itself. Wouldn't that
be also the the the one of the things
that happened in the cross as well? I I
don't know, pastor. What? Well, maybe
not so much at the cross, but by the
resurrection. The resurrection. Jesus
said, "Because I live, you will live
also." Yes. Uh the resurrection is the
guarantee of our resurrection. Amen. And
the reason why Jesus resurrected is
because the sins that he bore were not
his. M he was not guilty of those sins.
So the father raised him up. And so uh
the life of Christ is the hope of ever
our everlasting life. Amen. M in this
statement uh steps of Christ 27 the
knowledge of the plan of salvation which
means life death burial resurrection the
whole plan of so and and intercession
now in heaven will lead us will draw us
to Jesus to think of and el says this
throughout the caes ages of eternity the
the the idea of the condension condens
condescension condescension of Christ uh
to become part of us and then be
rejected by us uh and then die the death
on the cross and then minister on our
behalf will be something that we will
study and uh throughout all eternity and
we will get new meaning and
understanding even now as we contemplate
that it does draw us closer to the Lord.
It's a humbling thing to know that uh so
much was paid on our behalf. I think
that I would like to recommend uh one of
our newsletters from uh just maybe a
year ago. Mhm. Uh I wrote that uh
article in the newsletter. It's titled
uh reflections on upward and downward
mobility. You know, Lucifer had upward
mobility and God says I'm because you
had upward mobility, I'm going to cast
you down. On the other hand, Jesus had
downward mobility. He came down as a man
and went further down dying of death on
the cross. Therefore, at the end of the
passage in Philippians 2, it says,
"Therefore, God has highly exalted him
that in the name of Jesus, every knee
shall bow and every tongue confess."
Amen. That Jesus Christ is Lord to the
glory of the God the Father. Uh so, uh
you know, we need to learn from the
cross uh that downward mobility comes
before exaltation. Amen. Amen. That's
right. Amen. Amen. If you humble
yourself, you shall be glorified in due
time. Amen. We praise the Lord for that.
We trust that this program has been a
blessing to you and we thank Mr.
Anonymous or Ms. Anonymous for her or
his his or her questions because they
were good ones and they gave us a chance
to do some things. Our time has slipped
into eternity. We'll see you again soon.
Bye-bye and God bless.
[Music]